Now, the general form of what we've been seeing is called the Remainder
Theorem. Over all, the remainder theorem tells us that the remainder we'll get
when we divide a function f by x minus a is going to be equal to f of a.
Exactly what we get when we plug in a for the value of x into the function.
Now, their remainder actually has really interesting implications for graphs.
We'll see that when we let a function equal the division of two polynomials and
their remainder is not equal to zero we get some pretty cool graphs. We'll end
up seeing things like this. The remainder's instantly involved in the way that
the curve breaks into these different pieces. We'll come back to that later,
though. We don't need to worry about this for now.